good evening welcome to Washington I'm
Bret Baier breaking tonight the wrong
kind of fourth of July fireworks a
brutal weekend across the country for
gun violence hundreds shot dozens killed
Chicago particularly dangerous to
children killed there in Georgia also
the governor has declared a state of
emergency calling in the National Guard
to protect citizens after the shooting
death of an eight-year-old girl
it all comes amid a serious situation
over the weekend in which the shootings
the governor declaring a state of
emergency to protect citizens after the
shooting of an eight-year-old girl in
Georgia it's coming as we have to Fox
team coverage tonight brit hume with a
divisive 'no stand right on this weekend
of what we heard over the weekend we
also have Kristen Fisher at the White
House with the president's comments
about the violence but we start off with
correspondent Matt Finn in the situation
in Chicago Matt Bret Georgia's governor
will deploy as many as 1000 National
Guard troops to protect state buildings
and the governor's mansion which the
governor says will allow law enforcement
to patrol the streets here in Chicago
for years now the president has
suggested sending in federal manpower to
help curb the violence here which once
again plagued this city over the holiday
weekend I see my daughter on the table
with a gunshot wound to the forehead
seven-year-old Natalia Wallace was shot
in the head and killed over the weekend
in Chicago as she played outside with
her siblings visualised the
seven-year-old shot bleeding to death
why the family is there also among the
innocent victims police say 14 year-old
Fernando Jones was shot and killed by
gang members on the 4th of July show
cago police say nearly 90 people were
shot since the beginning of the long
weekend on Thursday 17 people were
killed
even though 1200 additional officers
were added to the streets for the
holiday today Chicago's Police
Superintendent David Brown says there is
quote no consequences for illegal gun
possession in Chicago
he's demanding stricter sentences and is
publicly criticizing the quote
decision-makers who he says are
releasing repeat violent offenders and
many of these people come right back to
the very communities where they've
committed their crimes to commit more
crimes in New York at least eight people
were killed in 44 shot over the weekend
after what was reportedly the city's
bloodiest June in 24 years
NYPD's former Commissioner is blasting
Mayor Bill DeBlasio calling him
atrocious for eliminating the anti-crime
unit along with the city's million
dollar cut to the police department for
another 18 months and then very very
discouraged in Atlanta police say 24
people were shot Saturday night into
Sunday three of those people died
including this eight-year-old girl when
someone opened fire on her mother's car
you can't blame this on the police
officer you can't say that we this is
about criminal justice reform this is
about some people carrying some weapons
who shot up a car with a 8 year old baby
in the car for what New York Mayor New
York Mayor Bill de Blasio has responded
to some of the weekend violence they're
saying it's directly related in part to
people being cooped up during the
pandemic Brett Pat Finn live in Chicago
Maddox